[Music]
the vast environments of the video game
monster hunter world are home to
incredible forms of life
from thundering behemoths
to ravenous hunters
while the game focuses on battling
monsters every creature on this
continent has a life of their own with
unique day-to-day patterns biological
intricacies and roles to play in the
larger ecosystems so for this entry into
the archive we'll show the life of this
continent in entirely new ways and bring
you closer to these creatures than ever
before and although doing field work in
this region represents a significant
risk i'm determined to document these
extreme life forms firsthand so let's
embark on this expedition together and
discover what awaits in a land of giants
on the southern shores of this enormous
continent one of the first human
settlements lies in the shadow of the
surrounding wilderness the village of
astera is walled off from the dangers of
the region's interior and will serve as
a useful base of operations for this
voyage i'm staying in an accommodation
that my host assures me is in no way a
hastily converted storage room the
ceiling doesn't seem particularly
waterproof but even in these humble
lodgings i can smell the promise of
discovery or perhaps that's the smell of
dirty laundry in either case with the
sun just beginning to rise i check my
supplies one last time and set off
towards the wilderness beyond the safety
of astera's walls
to the west the most impressive forest
on the continent awaits
this age-old environment is aptly called
the ancient forest and it is a garden of
wonders from sunlit clearings to
dizzying heights each region of the
ancient forest is an ecosystem unto
itself
beginning in a clearing along the
shoreline i find a herd of slow-moving
herbivores basking in the morning sun
these are aptanos and despite their size
they are among the gentlest species on
the continent
they spend their days grazing on
plentiful vegetation and enjoying long
sips of water from the streams that flow
through this region
indeed i find aptonoths are so
mild-mannered i can walk among them in
safety close observations reveal the
aptonauts live in multi-family units
with infant aptanos never straying too
far from the watchful eye of a parent
for the ancient forest conceals many
dangers and while aptonauts have evolved
an impressive spiked club at the end of
their tales for defense they're
creatures in this environment that might
consider even the mightiest aptonath
nothing more than an appetizer to find
such life forms i'll have to venture
deeper into the forest
at the edge of the ancient forest the
vegetation becomes thicker and the
branches cast long shadows over the
undergrowth and slinking among the
foliage is a stealthy social predator
these are jagras nimble reptilian
lifeforms whose mottled green and yellow
coloration helps them blend into their
environment relatively small by the
standards of this continent a single
jagras couldn't hold their own against
most of the creatures that live here but
like a wolf pack the jagras have solved
this problem by sticking together they
travel together hunt together and when
one of them gets a kill
they eat together while they hunt in
groups of two or three innis spoils are
split among all members of the pack and
with so many mouths the meals rarely
last
when all scraps have disappeared the
different units silently split off once
more continuing their persistent search
for unwary prey and jagras don't just
hunt on the forest floor their sinewy
bodies are perfect for prowling across
the branches above in a forest whose
branches form a network of natural
causeways an attack can truly come from
anywhere i'll have to stay on my guard
as i venture deeper into jagras
territory
peeking out from the underbrush i
glimpse the entrance to a cave that the
jagras use as a nest
and from this opening a titan emerges
this is a great jagras a well-muscled
several ton behemoth that lumbers
through the forest in search of food
while i at first assume the great jagras
to be a separate species from the
smaller jagras they're actually a highly
specialized member of the pack like a
silverback gorilla the great jagras is
bigger and heavier than the other group
members and they have to be for the
great jagras doesn't feed on small
forest life like their jagras packmates
they feed on aptonoths adult aptonos and
to take down creatures as large as
aptonoths the great jagras will need to
be quick and decisive once they catch
the scent of their quarry the great
jagras is off charging with surprising
speed
in an instant the chase is over and the
great jagras swallows their prey
whole this alarming display might seem
truly monstrous but we can find similar
behavior in various earth animals
crocodile jaws aren't wired to move
sideways so they can't chew and must
instead swallow chunks of food whole the
same is true for certain snakes which
have evolved to gulp down prey larger
than their skulls thanks to a stretchy
elastic ligament in their lower jaw bone
we can assume the great jagras have
converged on a similar jaw structure
once a great jagras has swallowed their
prey they need to make a quick exit with
a full gullet weighing them down they're
vulnerable to predation and move with
caution but eventually this great jagras
drags their way back to the safety of
the nest here the great jagras heaves up
a portion of their meal and lets out a
roar on cue the other jagras rush in and
consume the leftovers that their larger
packmate has left them this extra
nutrition will help the smaller jagras
survive this dynamic is certainly a bit
disgusting but far from unheard of in
the animal kingdom various types of
birds bring food back for their young in
a similar manner and while the great
jagras isn't the parent of the jagras
they do assume a kind of parental role
within the pack providing food and
protecting the nest against various
outside threats
but there is one life form that can slip
past the great jagras unseen the kulu
yaku is a bird-like species that is
remarkably crafty and knows all the ins
and outs of the ancient forest and most
notably the kulu yaku has memorized when
the great jagras leave the nest to hunt
which helps the kulu yaku score their
favorite food jagras eggs on earth many
generalist predators consume the eggs of
ground nesting birds to supplement their
diet but the kulu yaku isn't stealing
bird eggs but rather the eggs of a life
form many times their size so this bird
brain will need to be careful sneaking
into jagras territory the kulu yaku
pauses at the nest's entrance they know
that if they're caught in the act
they'll be in serious trouble
but fortune favors the bold descending
into the cave their prize awaits egg in
hand there's no point in hesitating
running is now the best strategy the
further they can get from the nest the
better
safe at last
holding the egg in their long forelimbs
the kulu yaku digs in this heist was
successful but the next one might not be
but the kulu yaku isn't as helpless as
they might appear when threatened the
kulu yaku will pick up a rock and use it
to fend off other life forms i learned
about this behavior when i followed one
too closely and they tried to bash me
over the head fortunately the kulu yaku
is rather cowardly and once i stood my
ground they turned away tailing them
more cautiously i noticed the kulu yaku
will also use their flexible digits to
scratch in a very human-like manner
leaving brilliant feathers behind on the
forest floor the kulu yaku might be on
the small side for this environment but
with the keen intellect they're able to
eke out a life here
yet every environment needs an apex
predator for the lower reaches of the
ancient forest that predator is the
anginath a huge bipedal hunter the
anginath can feed on just about anything
that walks upon the ground even a great
jagras is hopelessly outmatched against
the terror that is the anginath but the
anginath didn't reach the top just by
being the biggest to maintain their
status within the food web of the lower
forest this species has evolved an array
of unexpected adaptations
the engineers knows for example
is a strange fleshy appendage on the tip
of their snout that extends when
tracking prey and greatly enhances the
creature's sense of smell like the nose
of a bear the anginath snout contains
hundreds of times more scent receptors
than a human's it's an odd looking
sniffer to be sure but a highly
effective one for the anginath having
such a large nose also means a frequent
buildup of mucous which the anginath
habitually sneezes out to mark their
territory it's certainly a gross
strategy although the pungent mixture
does send an unmistakable signal to
others that this district is taken and
this isn't the only bewildering
adaptation of the anjanath when charging
into battle the anginath extends two
massive sails from their back which help
the anginath appear even larger and
these sails have another function in a
tropical climate like this one a
creature as large as an anginath is in
danger of overheating and by extending
these sails the anginath can radiate
heat outwards while lying in the shade
certain lizards like iguanas have
similar sails under their neck that help
with thermoregulation
the anginath might be formidable but
like all creatures in the ancient forest
they are more than just a monster
further to the north the forest gives
way to a shimmering seascape
along this coast a herd of castodons
stretch their legs like the aptonauts
the castadons are herbivores and have
evolved numerous defenses to survive in
this ecosystem of teeth and claws
casted on skulls possess an extremely
thick roof this allows them to charge
potential threats without fear of
injuring their skulls a behavior i
observed firsthand when i crept too
close
from a safe distance however the
kestodon herd appears remarkably
peaceful curiously male casted on skull
plates are more extravagant likely to
aid in intra-species combat battles for
dominance are a familiar sight on earth
with numerous types of animals competing
with other members of their own species
often at the risk of their own life but
based on my limited observations casted
on herds seem more diplomatic in a
biosphere of vicious competition it's
nice to see a species that's a bit more
group oriented
other species have less pleasant
dispositions in the spore-filled region
at the northeastern edge of the forest
an ill-tempered omnivore patrols their
hunting path this brightly coloured
creature is a phuket phuket and while
they are only a medium-sized organism
they have a giant trick up their sleeve
or rather in their mouth the phuket
phuket's tongue is nearly as long as the
creature themselves and can be used like
a whip to stun other life forms the
equally chromatic chameleons have a
similar tongue to body ratio and like
the pukeipuke can lash out with their
tongues with blazing speed but the puke
puke is more than a one-trick life form
during one of my many observation
sessions one specimen launched a glob of
a toxic compound quite near my head as
it turns out the puke puke is a highly
venomous species thanks in part to their
unique diet the puke puke feeds
primarily on the toxic seeds of the
plants that flourish in this region of
the forest and can turn their food into
a deadly mixture within their stomachs
on earth cinnabar moths are known to
ingest poisonous plants and convert them
into toxins of their own within their
own bodies the puke puke don't just spit
liquid venom however but can also
release a foul gas cloud that is deadly
to breathe
despite this harrowing display of power
to my surprise the tiny terror soon
retreats further observations show that
the puke phuket is the bully of the
ancient forest terrorizing small
creatures but flying away in the face of
anything that seems threatening not such
a scary life form after all
all sorts of smaller creatures inhabit
the thick and lush greenery of the low
forest living through their own daily
dramas unbeknownst to the tree shaking
titans this region is known for yet the
role these tiny critters play in the
ecosystem shouldn't be overlooked and
while there are too many to name one in
particular stands out the moss wine
these delightful creatures spend their
days sniffing out their favorite food
which in the moss wines case happens to
be mushrooms at a glance the snuffling
moss wine resemble an earth pig or wild
boar with the notable addition of a bed
of moss that seems to be growing from
the fur on their back
this coating of moss forms as a result
of the moss wine's largely inactive
lifestyle and helps them blend into the
green of the underbrush various types of
sloths can be seen with plant matter
growing on their fur for a similar
reason yet unlike the sloth the moss
wine's role in the ecosystem of the
forest they inhabit is absolutely
critical according to my research
through their natural routines the moss
wine keeps the population of fungus at a
healthy level affecting the balance of
the entire region
yet there is one life form so ravenous
they can throw the entire forest out of
balance this heavily scarred colossus is
a devil joe and they are a stranger to
the ancient forest the devil joe is a
nomadic hunter known for wandering vast
distances in search of prey their status
as a super predator allows them to
overtake the territory of organisms that
stand in their path as a result the
devil joe wreaks havoc on any ecosystem
they invade on our own planet invasive
predators like lionfish in the north
atlantic pose a similar threat organisms
adapted for one environment that moved
to another either by their own accord or
in the lionfish's case human negligence
often find themselves in an ecosystem
with prey that have no defenses against
their specific hunting strategy and the
devil joe are no different thankfully
however the devil joe seemed to be few
in number indeed with so few devil joe
on this continent many seem unhealthy
due to low genetic diversity soon the
biosphere of the forest may be free of
their influence
i've now explored the lower reaches of
the ancient forest yet there is a new
world waiting in the branches above home
to even more extreme forms of life it's
a long and dizzying climb upwards best
not to look down
while making the trek upwards i cross
paths with a seldom glimpsed wonder this
enigmatic traverser of the treetops is a
toby kadachi a stealthy loner the tobi
kadachi can move cat-like across the
branches and the toby kadachi has a
secret ability periodically the creature
will brush up against nearby objects as
a result vast amounts of static
electricity collect in the tobi
kadachi's specialized spines which they
can unleash upon any creature that
bothers them
on earth honeybees are known to beat
their wings at such a fast rate that
they generate an electrical charge which
they use to help them keep track of
which flowers they've pollinated
static electricity typically isn't
strong enough to cause much damage
however which is why hunters like the
electric catfish generate their shocks
using specialized electric organs in
considering the paralyzing power the
tobii kadachi zaps seem to have i'd
theorize that they also have some form
of internal electric organ with this
scuffle over with the tobi kadachi
retreats higher up into the canopy with
an impressive leap they return to their
nest high in the branches and stretch
out for the equivalent of an afternoon
cat nap considering the power the toby
kadachi possesses it's best to continue
on and not disturb their slumber
at long last i reached the highest point
of the forest here at the crown of the
canopy a curious environment is waiting
this large clearing is defined by
charred wood and piles of discarded
bones it almost seems like a single
giant nest
but for what
from the sky comes the answer this is a
rathalos a flying life form in the true
ruler of the ancient forest the rathalo
spends their days soaring over their
domain on vast wings occasionally
touching down to feed upon the life
forms below when a rathalos feels
challenged they will end disputes
quickly with a powerful jet of
internally produced flame
and since any given rathalos must
maintain a wide territory they've
evolved to be quite aggressive towards
intruders i think it would be wise for
me to stay out of sight yet as the sun
sets i managed to observe another side
to these widely feared creatures i watch
this rathalos preen their scales while
they sit atop their treetop throne
before curling up and going to sleep for
the night while a rathalos could
certainly spell my doom while awake this
moment of stillness helps demonstrate
that many of these organisms while
powerful aren't truly monstrous
all the same i find i can breathe easier
once i'm back in the familiar glow of
civilization the village of astera is a
welcome sight after a long and risky
expedition and despite the still-present
smell of old laundry my accommodations
have never seemed better
elsewhere on the continent there are
more fascinating regions to explore and
more extreme life forms and i'll likely
set out on another expedition soon let
me know if you like this style of video
and want to see more
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry you can lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you